hey guys dr. Berg here in this video I'm
going to talk about the number one brain
focus tip if you have any lack of focus
or brain fog this video is for you and
have to do with something that's related
to alleged sugars okay when the blood
sugars go high use a whole series of
symptoms okay that relate to cognitive
function and your brain when the blood
sugars go low you have a whole series of
additional symptoms that can occur let's
just kind of talk about the difference
first so high blood sugar and that would
be mainly diabetics or pre-diabetics
brain fog headaches loss of memory and
focus vision issues your vision starts
going absent-mindedness
things like you go in a room you're like
okay what did I go in here for drowsy
that's for high sugar mainly it's going
to be sleepy though you're going to like
one take a nap and try to go to school
try to study when you're when your blood
sugars are high it's almost impossible
and then we have low blood sugars and
even diabetics they can have high low
depending on if they're taking their
medication and drops too low okay low
blood sugars forgetfulness anxiety from
worried to panic attacks nervous
irritable highly critical restlessness
depression confusion OCD I would venture
to say over 50% of the mental disorders
that a lot of psychiatrists use are
related to blood sugars but they never
look at the blood sugar issue at all
instead you put on a medication
unfortunately but it really does affect
the brain because the brain needs fuel
okay it could run on sugar fuel it can
also run on ketones we'll get into that
in a second but the point is this blood
sugar issues are related to consuming
too much sugar that's one thing
consuming too much refined carbohydrate
the worst advice for a diabetic or
anyone for that
to have five small meals a day and
spread out and have snacks because every
time you eat you spike insulin so
insulin is the issue and there's a
condition called insulin resistance if
you watch my videos you pretty much know
all about it if you don't click the link
below because that's very important but
here's that here's an interesting
situation you see these commercials on
people being tired and consuming a
energy drink or a Snickers bar all
you're doing is you're temporarily for a
minute spiking and then boom you end up
with brain fog maybe five minutes later
so what happens is over time when you do
that is you have this this blood sugar
that the door that opens the blood sugar
into the brain is insulin so that's the
hormone that regulates that sugar and
over time that door becomes resistant to
sugar so it neat takes more and more and
more sugar to create that effect and so
in other words your body is resisting it
so basically consuming sugar starves
your body of sugar fuel over time okay
and it takes ten years for a
pre-diabetic or insulin resistant client
to turn into a diabetic so this could
happen below the radar for many many
years the problem in the medical
community is that they don't really
recognize a hypoglycemia for example
unless it shows up on a blood test and
they're mainly using several tests like
a fasting glucose test well what they
should do is check a fasting insulin
test which is a lot better and that's
going to show the subclinical
issues because we want to know what's
happening to that insolent okay now
here's the point the point is over time
your brain becomes less sharp more foggy
and it becomes more sensitive sugar you
might not connect the dots at first
you're just going along and you're
eating the regular things and you're
wondering why you're just you're losing
your cognitive function so I'm going to
show you what to do to get it back and
fast it's the simplest thing but you
really need to realize that it is a
blood sugar problem even though it might
not show up on a blood test and and
that's probably why
when you eat sugar you feel better
temporarily but then you crash and burn
so we constantly are trying to raise the
sugar up when it's kind of coming down
but your brain would be much better if
it ran on a different fuel source and
it's called ketones and to do that you
have to consume you actually have to
drop your your sugars way way down it's
close to zero as possible actual added
sugar and things like that and you would
compensate by adding a little bit more
fat but over time the consumption of
excess sugar and refined carbs will
decrease oxygen to the brain okay so
that's probably one of the reasons also
why when you exercise you might feel
better with your blood Sugar's because
you got the surge of oxygen and also it
helps to temporarily kind of adjust your
blood sugars also the brain becomes
atrophied it's small over time with too
much sugar I mean what do they feed you
in the hospitals it's all sugar right
it's just it's insane when I broke my
shoulder when I fractured my shoulder I
was in the hospital and you can't eat
before surgery for a period of time so I
was literally starving and so I get the
surgery and then I am i wake up and i am
just so hungry and of course what do
they have jello crackers yogurt with
sugar i mean i just ate it and man did i
have a crash after that blood sugar
crash so i'm looking at this situation
it's just like no wonder people have a
lot of issues with going to the hospital
and trying to get healthy right now here
we go
atrophy and then starvation so basically
sugar starves your brain of fuel or
sugar over time because you'll develop a
condition called insulin resistance okay
so that's that is what what's going on
so what we want to do is you must do
several things we're off the bat you got
to cut out the sugar you have to stop
eating sugar okay anything sweet you
have to cut it out including honey and
agave nectar all that stuff yeah that's
number one number two
stop snacking between meals so those two
things are the most important regardless
of what else you ain't I mean if you
just did those two things you would
probably do very well so what I like to
do is in the morning
I don't eat unless I'm hungry so like
this morning I went till 11 o'clock
before I ate breakfast why because if
you eat when you're not hungry
you'll spike insulin and then all of a
sudden it comes down and guess what
you're going to be hungry again you're
going to be craving sugar again or or
just be hungry in general so basically
eating creates more hunger so 11 so
right now it's probably around 220 and
I'm not eating lunch and probably until
4:00 I'll probably little 4 and I'll
have my late lunch I'll probably just
had 2 meals a day and my body can do
quite well on that but the point is that
you don't want to eat when you're not
hungry
and then when you eat have protein
healthy fat I'll put the links down
below with specifics and then you want
to do a lot of greens a lot of salad and
let a vegetable things like that you
don't want to do a front grain also what
kills people is that going out to the
restaurants to often go to the
restaurant and it's really hard to find
food without them bringing the bread
last night I went to a restaurant and
first thing they brought was the bread
okay and they put it right in front your
face well you're already going in there
a little hungry right so it's really
tempting for a lot of people the bread
and then you have the dessert and you
have the wine the whole thing
the point is that it's very dangerous to
go to a restaurant and let's hear your
blood Sugar's are in control and you
don't have a problem with blood Sugar's
because look at when the blood Sugar's
go low you're not in your right mind
you're kind of you're not going to be as
rational you're not going to be as
disciplined so that's the danger going
to a restaurant because it's too open
for the wrong options okay so anyway I
wanted just to create a video on this I
hope some of this kind of put things in
perspective but if you want to get your
focus back
have to fix your blood Sugar's thanks
for watching